le 30 mai nous nous sommes réunis des
milliers pour créer les républicains ce
congrès de création des républicains
n'étaient pas une fin c'était un
commencement le commencement d'une
opposition dynamique forte créative qui
doit préparer l'alternance nous voilà
devant un engagement tenu par le
président nicolas sarkozy il s'était
engagé devant les militants il ya
plusieurs mois a provoqué le changement
de nom de notre famille politique c'est
chose faite avec aujourd'hui les
républicains
les républicains ça rappelle ce qu'est
le coeur même de notre adn politique
la réalité c'est qu'avant d'être
démocrate chrétien avant d'être
gaulliste avant des libéraux nous sommes
des républicains des républicains c'est
la famille politique du xxième siècle
l'objectif c'est de rassembler tous les
français qui souhaitent que notre pays
change profondément la promesse de faire
de la politique autrement et de
revisiter notre devise républicaine
liberté égalité fraternité
un mouvement plus démocratique plus
paritaires dans lequel les militants
seront beaucoup mis à contribution un
particulier centralisée avec plus de
pouvoir laisser à nos cadres à nos
adhérents sur le terrain un parti plus
moderne un parti beaucoup plus numérisé
et là aussi c'est la chance que nous
adhérons puisse s'exprimer
plus directement être républicain c'est
quoi être républicain c'est défendre le
travail
être républicain c'est croire dans la
méritocratie à l'école est républicain
s'est refusée le communautarisme et
défendre les valeurs de la laïcité
être républicain c'est en avoir un c'est
de constater en silence notre pays perd
progressivement toutes ces valeurs est
républicain c'est avoir envie de
remettre la france la tête à l'endroit
nous allons défendre nos valeurs celles
de la liberté d'abord liberté
d'initiative liberté d'entreprendre
liberté de créer liberté de travail et
la liberté c'est sans doute le plus beau
mot qui existe dans la langue française
eh bien c'est la famille des
républicains qui mieux que quiconque le
défendra demain et républicain c'est
aussi un pari celui de rassembler toutes
les françaises et tous les français qui
n'en peuvent plus de pouvoir socialiste
qui est incapable de nous libérer
la préoccupation majeure des français
qui est le chômage est bien évidemment
du front national ferait pire encore
l'unité sera notre force aujourd'hui je
suis très fier d'appartenir aux
républicains parce qu'avant toute chose
je suis français républicain je suis
républicain est français parce que je
crois que c'est la grille qui protège et
que c'est sans doute parce qu'il n'y a
pas d'état républicain au sens état de
droit du terme qu'il n'y a pas de
liberté
les républicains vont maintenant se
projeter dans l'avenir
préparer un projet d'alternance moderne
fort en rupture avec tout ce que la
france a connu en rapport avec le
socialiste ses impôts ses règles
l'étouffement de toute capacité
d'initiative
rejoignez nous
le nous serons nombreux que l'alternance
que nous sommes en train de préparer
sera forte et permettra de donner aux
jeunes français de nouveau dû nous
raisons d'espérer
ce n'est pas un rêve ce n'est pas une
utopie c'est juste notre ambition la
république de la confiance
voilà pourquoi nous sommes devenus ce
soir les républicains